- [Narrator] This is Sarita.
She's a cotton-top tamarin,
one of the smallest primates in the world.
After years of being poached
and captured in the wild,
the already endangered cotton-top
now faces the rapid
destruction of its habitat.
Cotton-tops are native to South America
and can only be found in
a limited forested area
of northwest Columbia.
They makes their homes in trees there
and enjoy a diet of fruits and insects.
Although exceedingly rare in the wild,
cotton-tops are recognizable by the shock
of white hair on their heads.
These primates are social creatures.
They live in hierarchical family groups,
led by a dominant pair
of mating cotton-tops,
and the pair's offspring are raised
communally by the group.
For many years, their
numbers were decimated
by the illegal pet trade
and their capture for biomedical research,
but today, deforestation
is the main culprit
behind their dwindling numbers.
Their wild population has shrunk by 80%
over the past three generations.
They're holding on by
the tips of their claws.
This is the cotton-top tamarin.